donc on vous a réuni ce soir pour vous
annoncer son divorce
ah non on divorce avec sa bombe à lui
enfin moi elle - utah top ton père ta
mère c'est une blague réussi je comprend
pas qui part alors moi qui veut là qu'un
des enfants oui je comprends pas soit
vous vous mettez d'accord sur des
accords soit ça sera aux enfants de
décider du moment à me dire que ma place
et dirige y toi vas pas t'as pas une
magic sion n'avait pas vivre avec toi tu
as eu cela dit ça non pollution
les actus veux tu veux la guerre tu m'as
pas stockable à moi je veux la guerre tu
veux si je venais dont je veux la guerre
tu m'aurais dit court 1
dans laquelle tu as fait c'est bien ce
qui est trop court oui mais ça allège
moins de mead ça fait mal à moins d'un
mètre
oui ça fait très mal qu'est ce qu'elle a
ma puce
donc papa va prendre un appartement
juste à côté de chez maman bien bonjour
je me suis plié la banque atteindra 2
vainqueur je suis même la victoire
on leur demande de choisir entre leur
père leur mère c pas compliqué quand
même cette histoire